All right, let's see. Looks like we got
ourselves a clown, y'all.
>> What the earth?
>> Looks like we got ourselves a clown. Yo.
>> Yo, who this,
>> man? What it do, man?
>> Yo, what's good, my boy?
>> Man, what you what you over here talking
about, man? What? What you talking
about, dog?
>> What I'm Well, you you heard me when I
said, "Why would I debate a man
worshipper?"
>> No, I I actually just got in. So, I
heard something about man worshipper. I
didn't hear the part before that.
>> Oh, yeah. Yeah. I said, "Why would I
debate a man worshipper?" Like like you
down here, we worship the heavens, the
God of the heavens and the earth. The
man worship us way down here. Like
>> but you worship a man though. I'm
confused.
>> Why you telling me what I worship? That
don't make no sense.
>> You're a Muslim, right?
>> Yeah, I'm a Muslim. You worship the God
of the heavens and the earth.
>> No, you don't. You worship a man who
claims to be the God of the heavens and
the earth.
>> Nah, that's not what Muslims believe.
You got that you got your information in
correct. I ain't going to lie.
>> I I know it's not what you believe. The
point is is that that's what your Quran
teaches. Like like for example, you you
you would agree that men a man needs a a
wife in order to have a kid, right? In
order to have a
>> bro nobody who know who ever listen read
Islam like you could try to reason it
what however you
>> however way you want but no person who
read the Quran and no Muslim know that
Muslims don't worship a man like this is
common knowledge.
>> Okay. So I know what you're talking
about.
>> So So let me ask you, would you agree
that uh uh that men need a mate in order
to have a son?
>> That men need a mate in order to have a
son. Yeah, that's what that's what
people need. Hell yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, the Quran says that same
thing about Allah. It says Allah needs a
mate in order to have a son.
>> Anything anything needs an equal to have
a child.
>> Yeah. It sounds like a man to me. Sounds
like just like a man. That's that's a
man. God doesn't need no equal in order
to have a son. need to have a son of his
own substance. But Allah needs a man
just like I mean I'm sorry. Allah needs
a mate just like any man does.
>> Well, that would go against that would
go against any human understanding. Like
>> bro,
>> like if you got if if your God wants to
go against like it wants to make a
creation that don't that you know that
doesn't have the intellect to understand
his nature, then you what you saying is
correct. But our God reasons the way the
way we reason and he he you know and
that is that if he doesn't have a
co-equal, how is he going to h if he
doesn't have a mate? How is he going to
have a
>> I don't I don't mean to cut you, man,
but uh I don't want you to get banned on
TikTok either. You sure Tik Tok won't
get you for this?
>> No, don't worry about that.
>> Okay. I I want this to last long, man.
>> I mean, don't worry about it. I mean
>> Okay. All right. Well, so uh so just
like any man needs a mate or needs an
equal of its of his own kind in order to
have a son, then um that's Allah. Allah
also needs exactly what man needs in
order to have a son. So you you worship
a man, but you're accusing others of
being man worshippers. You're no
different than what you're accusing
other people of being. It's probably
worse actually cuz you don't even know
it.
>> Now what you what you're saying is not
following at all. If somebody say how
can they have a son the the the thing is
for you to answer the question like when
the law poses a question the
disbelievers they don't answer the
question
>> he already does
>> he's asking a logical question how is he
going to so how is he going to have a
son
>> Mhm. If he does not have a mate, sure
that's answering you answer.
>> I can I can answer that. Yeah, I can I
can answer that. But notice what I I'll
give you the answer and then I'll show
>> Don't you deny and I'll show you what
right now.
>> I'll give you the answer.
>> God can have a son from his own
substance. He can be get a son from his
own substance without any help. Without
the need of a mate, he can be get from
his own substance. He doesn't need help
because he's God. He's all powerful. But
Allah, he's not actually challenging you
to answer the question. He's actually
refuting the logic of the humans who are
saying that he has children. He's saying
how can I have a son when I don't have a
mate. So Allah himself is making it
clear that he cannot have a son without
a mate just like how humans can't have
children without mates. He's just like
us.
>> We going to we're going to go we're
going to answer your um we're going to
go back to your answer that you said.
You said he can have a a child from his
own substance. This is you putting
together words. But from his substance,
what what what is um what persists of
his substance, right? What is his
substance?
>> Eternality, all powerfulness, knowledge.
>> Okay. Boom.
>> All of that. Boom.
>> All of this stuff.
>> Boom. All right. He can have a son from
his own from his own substance, but
Allah can't. He's He's just like boom.
Boom. All right. Then you answer my
question already. Being eternal, being
all powerful. You said these two. Now,
does a son have to uh does a son take on
a trait like a offspring? Do they take
on traits of their suffering?
>> Of course.
>> Okay, that's impossible. You can't have
a son, you can't have you um someone
can't have also have a trait of
eternity. Now, that's two that's two
eternities. That's impossible.
>> No, it's one eternity just two distinct
persons who share that same eternity.
That's all.
>> But if he begot, then he had a son. He
begotten. So it's not just two
eternities.
>> It would it would have to be something
>> one eternity and and then he begott
two eternities.
>> It would be something done not in time.
God can be get outside of time which
would mean it's an eternal action that
happens not something that takes place
in time.
>> What we go with logic we go with logic.
>> You just saying you saying okay now you
have a son outside of time. Now mind you
we still answering the same question. So
then you have so then you brother you
have to deal with then if you're going
to reject that and say nuhuh nuhuh
nuh-uh that's fine you can hold your
position then you have to answer for
Allah being incapable of having a son
without a mate just like men do. You're
saying that you're you're going against
man worshippers but all everything in
the Quran is showing me that Allah is a
man like us. Well, you already first of
all this a man what when you say a man
worshipper we mean I don't you can
you're trying to like put together this
thing of how but a man is somebody who
is not god correct he does not have god
qualities correct
>> a mere man
>> he does not have the god substance
correct
>> a mere man sure
>> all right so all right so what you would
be doing is what what your job is
supposed to be is to prove that he
doesn't have to prove that Allah doesn't
have the god substance
for the fact we we already know.
>> Okay. You saying what what's what
doesn't he have of God? You mention Hold
on. You mentioned two things.
>> Let me let me just let me just You
mentioned two things that part of the
God all powerful and eternity. We
already know God Allah has these things.
So
>> No, he doesn't. Okay.
>> He doesn't.
>> All right. So, let's talk about it.
>> I prove that Allah says,
>> what does it mean to be all powerful?
>> It means that you're over all things
capable. You're more you're capable to
do whatever anything can do. You can
you're more capable of doing.
>> Absolutely. And you don't need any help.
You're not dependent on anything to do
anything that you want to do. Right.
>> That's uh that's would be self-
sustaining,
>> right? Which would mean all powerful.
You in order to be all powerful, you
have to be self-sustaining. Correct.
>> Yeah. Yep.
>> Okay.
>> So that would mean
>> so so to be all powerful means that you
are capable of doing all things. Nothing
is too hard for you and you don't need
help doing it. Okay. Now, here's part
two. Allah doesn't fit that category
because Allah cannot have a son by
himself. Allah would need help in order
to have a son. So therefore, he does not
have the quality of all powerfulness.
He's not all powerful.
>> Uh having a son is not a a powerful
thing. This is not something be
beginning children. This doesn't go into
power. This goes into a act that's given
to mankind that's given to creation.
Power is things that's powerful, right?
It's things like creating. He created
the heavens and the earth. He created
all creation. Everything that exists.
This is power. Now, if you can say he
didn't do this, this is okay. He's
lacking in power. But you saying, "Oh,
he didn't he didn't uh pick up a stick
or he didn't have a son." This is not
like this is not a powerful thing.
>> That's not what I'm saying.
>> It's not an example of power.
>> Cora. Cora, that's not what I'm saying.
Listen to my argument. Okay. My argument
is not that oh, he has to have a son in
order to be powerful. My argument is
that he couldn't have a son by himself.
Even if he wanted to, he would need
help. So if you need help to do
something, if you need if you depend on
something outside of yourself
>> for something, then you're not all
powerful. You're not self-sustaining.
>> You're you're mis you're misrepresenting
the Quran and what what Allah is saying.
>> Okay. Can Allah have a son by himself?
>> You saying you saying you're saying he
needs help to have a son? The point is
there's no point of having a son.
>> That's that's not the point at all, bro.
The point is can he do it?
>> Can he do it by himself? Could he do it?
>> If he could, he would have chosen from
one of his creation.
>> That's fine.
>> And he didn't even do that.
>> But could he do it? Could he do it by
himself? You
>> You're saying have offspring? You cannot
have offspring without a mate.
>> Okay. So Allah,
>> that's what offspring is. A offspring is
a is a child.
>> It's something of yourself. So Allah
cannot have a son.
>> No, that's not what
>> without Hold on. Allah cannot have a son
without help. In order for him to have a
son, he would need help, something
outside of himself in order to help him
to have a son. Therefore, he's dependent
and not all powerful. He's a limited
being. So, he he's not God. He does not
have the God substance,
>> bro. Yes.
>> Well, he does. You're not. So, what
doesn't he have of the God substance?
Because you believe Jesus, you believe
in be. So, it can't it can't possibly be
anything that Jesus has, right? Like
being a human being and dying, right? So
you you saying these things that you
actually believe in yourself and it's
not it's not following. You believe
Jesus died and that he's God. How is he
all powerful if he died,
>> right? And that people assassinated him.
And I'm not trying to switch the
subject. I'm not trying to switch the
subject. It's that you're bringing up
something that you believe No, no, no,
no. It's just that you're believing
you're you're bringing up something that
you believe in yourself,
>> right? And it's not uh we don't we don't
believe that he lacks any of these
substances.
>> Okay. So, how about this? How about we
table this and let's uh let's talk about
something else. You you down to talk
about Paul vers Muhammad?
>> Nope.
>> Oh, you So, you do So, you do agree?
>> I mean I mean we could I mean no we you
you yourself know that uh Paul was a
annihilator. A Christian annihilator. I
don't even know. I don't even know.
>> Yeah. Then he changed his way.
>> You do know he was annihilating
Christians, right?
>> Yeah, he was. And he changed his he
never had to change his
>> Yeah. Muhammad was Muhammad was a Jew.
He was a Jew and Christian annihilator,
wasn't he?
>> All right. All right. Get over my pain,
bro.
>> Oh, what?
>> Oh, well, you know what? I'mma bring
somebody. You You want to talk to
somebody else or or what?
>> Sure, I guess. What did I Wait, just
really quick, Corz. What I said was what
I said offensive.
>> You No, it's is you just uttering things
out your mouth that some people saying
you running. If you're just uttering, I
could say Jesus was a Muslim, right? You
wouldn't even take that, right? And so
>> I'll take that. You want to talk about
that?
>> Or or or g or or Jesus was or Jesus was
a white man or he was a Caucasian or,
you know, that he was the first human
being. I would just be uttering garbage
out my mouth.
>> Yeah. But I I didn't just utter I didn't
utter garbage by saying that Muhammad
annihilated Jews and and attempted to
annihilate Christians. Like that's
literal in
>> You said You said Yeah. It's not like
you said he was a Jew.
>> No, I said he annihilated Jews. He had
two He had two tribes of Jews
annihilated, bro.
>> Yeah. In the in the cause of Allah. And
I would believe is is it in the cause of
Allah.
>> You see, notice how you have an you have
you have a justification for what
Muhammad is doing. But notice I I can
say listen listen. I'm I'm just hear me
out.
>> That's not the case with
the cause of God.
>> Hear me out. And I and neither was
Muhammad. However, here's the thing. I
can say Kora, listen to what I'm saying.
I can say that Paul was wrong for
killing Christians and imprisoning
Christians. Can you say that Muhammad
was wrong for killing Jews and going out
to attack Christians?
>> So So you can say that because it's your
belief, right? That actually
it's in your belief that it's in that
it's wrong.
>> He is it in your belief that it's wrong?
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, bro.
>> Okay.
>> Before his conversion, he was doing
this. So he wasn't known as an upright
person. He wasn't known as a trustworthy
righteous person.
>> He was
>> that's the problem. So when he converts
and when he converts and himself
appoints himself as an apostle
automatically knowing okay yeah I seen
Jesus this is a problem. While before
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam became a prophet in his
community. He was known as being
righteous and you saying yeah he was but
you you just said what he was doing was
wrong. The prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he was known as being
righteous and trustworthy. never lying
and having upright character. Everybody
trusted him. So when the when the
message came, people believed him. This
is not the So when when people believe
Paul, I don't have no I have no idea why
people would believe him.
>> I got you. So saying that you don't know
why people would believe Hold on, dude.
>> You saying that you don't know why
people would believe him? That's I mean,
that's uh that's tough. I mean, let's
let's let's talk about that.
>> Let's talk about Well, let's talk about
it. Muhammad receives a revelation. Paul
receives a revelation, right? Both men
claim to receive revelation. Let's let's
look at these two together. Let's see
which one is more credible. Were there
any witnesses to uh Muhammad's
revelation in his ca in the cave?
>> Not not in the cave, but his the
revelation came through throughout a
case of throughout a a period of many
many years.
>> So So he says so he says. So
>> that's what you believe. I mean
>> I I I know I know it's what you believe,
but I'm doing I'm doing I'm critiquing
your belief. I'm critiquing your
sources. So, both both have plans.
You gota you gotta let me land. I don't
I don't have to. Your belief your belief
is not in reality. That's the point.
That's why that's why I'm debating you.
>> Well, that Well, you Well, that's what
we both believe about each other's
belief.
>> That's why we're talking about it.
That's why we're talking about it.
>> You're bringing up what you you bringing
up what happened in a cave by itself
when he got the revelation for 28 years.
Let's let's dishonest. [clears throat]
Did Did Paul have so I'm sorry. Muhammad
had no witnesses to his revelation in
the cave. Um but Paul had witnesses to
his revelation. He had the soldiers that
was with him. He also had Ananas who
also received a revelation that
confirmed Paul's revelation that he
received on the road to Damascus. Did
anybody else like just did anybody have
a revelation that confirmed Muhammad's
revelation?
>> No. He's the only one getting
revelation. So why would anybody else
get a
>> I got you. So he's a one
>> unless we going into the prophecies.
Unless we going into the prophecies.
>> I got you.
>> The Old Testament and in jail and all of
that stuff. But
>> so let me So let me ask you this then,
Cora. Let me ask you this. Think about
this with me. What do you think is more
credible? A person who doesn't have
witnesses claiming to have experienced
something solely on his own or someone
who does have witnesses to what he
experienced and not just witnesses but a
divine witnesses re revelation that
confirms what he
>> divine witnesses.
>> What do you think?
>> Well, you're oversimplifying it too much
because more details have to be
included. I just I just I know just out
of these two things, what do you think
is more credible?
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'm saying you're see uh
oversimplification is a form of
manipulation. Oversimplifying you're
you're over I'm I'm If you're manipulate
if you're being manipulative, I'm not
going to
>> I haven't manipulated anything. I just I
just put two side by side, bro. I put
>> Paul manipulated the first the first
example was manipulated because you you
lack the details of this. You just said
if someone is this enough evidence if if
someone says he got a revelation and
it's just him. The details that need to
be included here is that he was for 40
years he was someone who had upright
character and was trustworthy throughout
his life.
>> So you say so you say the same to be
said about Paul too. Who cares?
>> But that's but we we going to go with
what we believe in, right? You don't
believe that. So it can't be said about
him. Cora, think about this.
>> Bro, you you act like you act like
>> Cora, Slow down,
>> I'm appearing to
>> Slow down. Look, just think about this
for a second. Let's say I I I I'm 31
years old. Okay, let's say all my 30
years of living, I've been known to have
never lied. I've been known to be
trustworthy. I've been known to do good
to the poor.
>> I've been known to be a really good
person. And then I came out and said,
"Hey guys, God gave me a revelation."
>> Gave me a revelation. He came to me and
and now I am a prophet of God. Would
that would that mean would that mean
that I'm telling the truth? Does that
does that make what I'm saying?
>> That would be Yeah. Yeah. The your
reputation
with the community that you have never
did this is a proof for the community.
There's proof as long as time
>> is a proof for reality.
>> It's not just pro. It's a it's evidence.
It's reliability.
>> So, it's evidence that my
>> exper
you're not you're not letting me talk,
bro.
>> Go ahead. My bad.
>> If you go if you go into court, right,
and it's multiple people testifying, the
most reliable uh testimonies are a form
of proof. You understand this?
>> Wait, if you go if you go to court and
what?
>> Hold on. Let me let me finish. Let me
finish.
>> I'm trying to understand you.
>> Let me let me start from the beginning.
Test uh testifiers are a form of proof
>> people. Hold on. Hold on, bro.
>> What if there's no
>> Let me let me finish, bro. Let me
finish.
>> What if there's no testifiers? Would
that hurt the case?
>> Okay. Okay. Hold on, bro. Let me finish.
So, when people come up and speak their
evidence, a part of the evidence and and
what makes it more reliable evidence is
their reputation. Whether they have a
clean record, whether their people have
good things to say about them, and
mainly based off of their clean record.
So this makes the evidence stronger,
right? So based off of what I'm telling
you, right, is his EV uh his reputation
was clean.
>> I love that.
>> When whatever you say, so in your
example, if you was somebody who um who
was who spent 30 years being known as
righteous and trustworthy within the
community and you came with this message
that you got, first of all, in in this
case, it wasn't u he didn't just go say,
"I got a revelation from God like Paul."
He didn't know at first. He said, "I had
this this experience." And somebody else
came and said, "That's the angel." And
then he got more revelation confirming
that he was the angel. So if if you make
an analogous thing and say, "Yo,
something crazy happened to me and while
I was in the cave, right, we why would
we disagree with you? Why would we after
you spent 30 years being trustworthy?
This is this is um proof. This is
evidence."
>> Okay. Can I can I speak now? Okay. So So
Kora, I love your example, man. You use
your example as witnesses that testify
in a courtroom. Let me ask you this. Um,
you got two you got two uh two two
people who are being tried, right? The
accuser and the defendant, right? If the
defendant if the defend if the defendant
has witnesses to cooporate what he says
and his character and all that kind of
stuff. Yo,
>> we'll keep talking. I'mma send a quick
text. You are you, too. I'm going to
hear you.
>> All right. If you have if if the
defendant has witnesses to cooporate
what he says, where he's been, his
story, and so on and so forth. He has
witnesses testifying to back up what
he's saying. The accuser has no
witnesses. It's just him saying it's
just his own word of mouth. In the
courtroom, which case is more credible?
The defendant with witnesses or the
accuser with no witnesses?
>> Yeah, it depends. It depends on the
reputation.
>> Now, it depends.
>> If he bring Yeah, it it it does, bro.
Like I said, you can oversimplify stuff,
but I'm going to I'm going to make it
clear for the
>> You keep you keep shuffling from from
your own example. You just
>> Bro, like I said, you can oversimplify
it, but I'm going to clarify.
>> Just answer the question, bro. in the
courtroom, who is more credible, the one
with witnesses or the one without? Which
one?
>> Yeah, bro. If those witnesses are
untrustworthy with a record of lying all
the time, then there's a problem. Who
cares? You're a liar. Nobody trusts you
in the society. But if that accuser, if
the accuser is up is known for telling
the truth, right, is for me, this has um
this is going to count more. this or may
not even count more, but it'll count as
a count as I I heard you. This this is
why this is bad. The reason why this is
bad is because you just shifted the
goalpost. At first, you said if you have
witnesses that account for your
testimony and your character um and
cooporate you, then you have a good case
and you have proof. The witnesses are
the proof of your character and your
story. But now that I've given you your
same analogy and just added, okay,
there's somebody else with no witnesses.
You're saying, "Oh, well, you know, um,
no, it depends." Now, if the witnesses,
you see how you got to do that, man. You
see the games you got to play, bro.
>> Let me let me clarify what I said.
>> You got to change up your your own
analogy.
>> N you got what I said wrong. I didn't I
didn't say if an I didn't make the
accuser and a witness's analogy. That's
what you came with. I said if a person
is if a person testifies so this is what
this person is being held to account
right now. If a person testifies to
something his his uh character
[clears throat] and his reputation is
being is being account is being um you
know uh accounted for. So for those
testifiers I didn't make the I accuser
and the thing I didn't do all of that.
So if we use if we take one specific
testifier and we look at their
reputation and in their testimony they
their um them who's being forward
brought forward as evidence is is not
reliable and it's not for me is not
worth much.
>> Okay,
>> that's the that's the point I'm saying.
I did not make the accuser thing you did
that that's not me.
>> I got you. I got you. So I I'll ask my
question again, bro, since you ran away
from your own you just changed your your
own analogy.
>> Yeah, bro. Why don't I have
>> Okay, I'm sorry. Hopey only hopefully
you hopefully you answer this time. What
is more credible?
>> Uh a lone person with no witnesses at
all or a person who has witnesses and
even has a divine cooperation where
somebody else also has a revelation
confirming the revelation that they had.
>> Which side is more credible?
>> That's the 36. Oh, no. That's not I put
I put one of the 36ers in. Uh
>> he's moving that. That's where uh 2009's
going, right?
>> Oh, yeah. Yep.
>> Probably going to go ahead and leave
them to himself.
>> All right.
>> Got a bunch of 36.
>> I think we done it as far as the end of
the night, but right now
we got any more open.
>> Three. Three more 36.
>> Three. How many you have? Let me see.
>> I think I got one or two. Yeah.
>> Can you make sure there's at least three
in from now?
>> Okay. All right. All right, my fault,
bro.
>> That's all right. So, I asked which one
would be more credible? The one who has
no witnesses to his revelation or
someone who does have witnesses to his
revelation and has a another revelation
from somebody that also cooporates the
revelation they had? Which side is more
credible? But yeah, like I said, bro,
it's going to But I mean, if you take it
at face value, it's going to be the
person who has um who has first of all,
how the hell you getting witnesses of a
revelation? Like, how you get witnesses
that you've been revealed to me?
>> You you so you agree that this person
with the witnesses and who has even
another witness who has a revelation
that cooperates his revelation, that
person would have more credibility than
the one who has no witnesses. Right. But
okay, to be a witness to something, you
got to see it, right?
>> Brother, you're not answering my
question, bro. Please.
>> Cuz your question is not making no
sense. That's why
you were you were a cubits foot away
from answering the question and then you
started going off some off something.
Come on, man.
>> Because because as I'm speaking, I'm
thinking about the question. I'm like,
okay, it's it's like it's like if you
were witness to a dream, right? How the
hell you going to witness a dream? How
the hell are people going to witness my
dream? God could God could God give
someone a dream that cooperates somebody
else's dream?
>> Is that a is that Yeah, of course. But
is that a witness to the dream?
>> Yeah, it'll be a witness to the dream.
God, if if God brings a revelation, like
for example, you you know you know
Daniel, right? You know the story of
Daniel?
>> Yeah, I disagree with what you said.
Yeah. A person a person having the same
dream as somebody else
>> is not them witnessing the other
person's dream. So, whatever you about
to say,
>> I got you.
>> Don't make no sense.
>> Okay. Do you know you know the story of
Daniel, right? It looks like he probably
got a call or something.
>> Not notice how hard the Muslims have to
fight sense. You know, they have to they
they have to struggle and and think
their try their ways to think theirelves
out of what is common sense. You know, I
want to give him this last example and
then I'll and then I'll leave him alone,
guys. I'll give him this last example.
>> Cory, can you hear me?
>> Yeah.
>> Do you are you familiar with the story
of Daniel?
>> No, I'm not familiar with it.
>> Okay. Daniel was a prophet of God. He
was in Babylon and he used to serve King
Nebuchadnezzar. Nebuchadnezzar had a
really terrible dream. Nobody could
interpret the dream. But Daniel, he
came.
>> Daniel came
>> and he told he told Nebuchadnezzar what
his dream was and interpreted it by
God's by God's gift of revelation. Could
you agree with me that Daniel is a
witness to the dream Nebuchadnezzar had
>> because God gave him revelation of of
his dream? No.
>> No. Okay. All right. I'm leave I'm going
to leave you to yourself, man. Keep
enjoy Islam, bro.
>> Copy, bro. Little dude.
>> Absolute idiot.
>> Copy, bro.
>> Absolute idiot. Guys, is Islam is a is a
fungus. Islam is a fungus. Islam is an
absolute fungus. It's a cancer. It's a
cancer to sense. It's a cancer to logic.
It's a cancer to morality. It is a
cancer to thinking. It's a cancer to uh
comprehension. It's a cancer and fungus
to understanding. Islam is a fungus, a
sickness that needs to be burned away.
Y'all see this brother here? Y'all heard
him. Notice this. This isn't because
he's he he's a human being made in the
image of God just like you and me. All
of them. They're all made in the image
of God just like just like you and me.
We're all made in the same image of God.
And y'all y'all y'all see how deep this
stuff is spiritually. Islam makes you
spiritually stupid, spiritually dumb,
spiritually slow. You you can't you
can't accept sense in Islam. You can't
accept logic in Islam. You cannot accept
what is clear. You can't accept clarity
in Islam. That's That's Islam.